vamos a tomarnos un tiempo un pequeño
descanso de toda esta matemática
rigurosa que hemos construido acerca de
cómo definir un vector y cómo definir un
ángulo etcétera y a continuación quiero
pensar en algo que nosotros vamos a
utilizar bastante y es la idea de un
plano en r3 como encontramos una
ecuación que describa un plano en r3 una
ecuación de un plano en r3 y bueno
nosotros vivimos en un mundo
tridimensional entonces r3 es una cosa
muy cotidiana para nosotros y nosotros
queremos agarrar un plano en r3 pues
podemos pensar por ejemplo en el suelo o
en tu pantalla del monitor o en una
fotografía hay un buen de planos en este
mundo tridimensional así que déjame
dibujar t1 aquí tengo el eje de las x
aquí tengo el eje de las 10 voy a
ponerlo por acá este es mi eje de ayer
este es mi eje de las zetas y bueno ya
tengo mis tres ejes y voy a dibujar un
plano aquí en r3 voy a tomarme este
plano de aquí y este plano crece para
todos lados es un plano infinito en r3
ahora mi pregunta es cómo puedo yo
definir la ecuación de un plano en r3 y
seguramente tu día te debes de acordar
que nosotros teníamos que la ecuación a
x más bella
cz igual a d esto nos dibuja un plano si
nosotros tomamos las ideas de la
geometría analítica esto me va a dibujar
un plano y eso quiere decir que para
cualquier punto x jay-z que me tome aquí
en este plano entonces debe de
satisfacer esta ecuación pero a
continuación quiero definir un plano de
una manera un poco más formal quiero
pensar en un plan o utilizando álgebra
lineal todo lo que hemos construido con
las herramientas de álgebra lineal así
que vamos a tomar otro pregunto en este
plano voy a tomar este punto que va a
ser el punto x 0 10 070 y no
forzosamente tiene que ser el mismo
punto que tome aquí a la izquierda
pueden ser puntos distintos o puede ser
el mismo punto es más vamos a pensar que
es otro punto distinto este punto que
tenemos aquí ya continuación que voy a
hacer es tomarme un vector que tenga con
un punto inicial un punto en este plano
es más que tenga como punto inicial el
punto x 0 10/0 z 0 pero que sea
perpendicular
por lo tanto vamos a dibujarlo va a ser
este vector de aquí este vector de aquí
le voy a llamar el vector n porque a
este vector se le conoce como el vector
normal n es el vector normal y eso
significa que es un vector que es
perpendicular al plano el vector normal
es aquel vector que es perpendicular al
plano perpendicular al plano que tenemos
aquí entonces tenemos escribirlo
perpendicular al plano o perpendicular
mejor vamos a ponerlo así a todo punto
perpendicular a todo punto a todo lo que
esté en este plano que me estoy tomando
sé que suena un poco informal pero a
cualquier cosa que esté en el plano este
vector es perpendicular por lo tanto si
yo me tomo un vector en este plano
entonces el vector n o el vector normal
va a ser perpendicular a este efector
voy a decirle a que me voy a tomar
adentro del plano y bueno recordando lo
que vimos en vídeos pasados yo sé que si
tomo el producto punto de un vector aquí
de este vector al punto del vector n es
decir mi vector normal me va a dar 0
vamos a escribirlo en el punto am
ser igual a 0 porque son vectores
perpendiculares de hecho esto lo vimos
en el último vídeo cuando hablábamos de
ángulos nosotros decíamos que cuando dos
vectores sean perpendiculares su
producto punto entre ellos era igual a
cero por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer a
continuación es tratar de buscar una
forma en la que yo tome este vector
normal y le sume no se lo escribe aquí a
este vector normal le voy a sumar el
punto x 0 0 0 0 ya esto voy a intentar
que sea mi definición acerca de esta
ecuación que yo tenía que arriba lo que
quiero es que esto me defina la ecuación
a x más bella más zeta igual a 0 es
decir la ecuación de un plano así que
vamos a ver si lo podemos generar quiero
que esto me dé a x más bella más 60
igual a cero entonces qué es lo que
podemos construir lo primero que quiero
que nos fijemos es en estos dos puntos
que tenemos aquí si yo hablo del vector
el vector cuyas componentes son el x 0 0
z 0 me estoy refiriendo a un vector en
posición estándar es decir fíjate bien
a definir el vector x0 como el vector
cuyas componentes son x 0 y 0 0 y ojo no
es esto un punto es un vector cuyo punto
inicial está en el origen y cuyo punto
final está en el punto x 0,070 entonces
es este vector que tenemos aquí y si te
das cuenta no es un vector que está en
nuestro plano es un vector que está
afuera de nuestro plano y que llega a
tocar en un punto a nuestro plan no
solamente en el punto x 0 10/0 z 0 y de
igual manera voy a definir a otro vector
voy a definir al vector x que va a ser
el vector en posiciones estándar cuyas
componentes son x y z es decir es el
vector cuyo punto inicial está en el
origen y su punto final está en el x10 z
este va a ser un nuevo vector el vector
x que es el vector cuyas componentes son
x y z que es este vector de clima y de
igual manera ojo este no es un vector
que está en el plano es un vector que
está fuera del plano podríamos decir de
hecho que está abajo del plano y que
solamente toca el plano en un punto en
el punto x
y recuerda que estábamos diciendo que el
punto equis y zeda no era el mismo punto
que el punto x 00 cet a 0 así que fíjate
bien vamos a intentar dibujarla para que
me entiendas bien este es el plano que
yo tengo aquí y este va a ser un vector
x0 tenemos como su punto inicial el
origen y solamente tocamos al plano aquí
en este puntito en este puntito que es
el punto equis 0,0 z 0 y de igual manera
aquí tengo mi vector x mi vector x y mi
vector x0 comparten el punto inicial que
es el origen porque ambos están en
posiciones estándar y mi vector x
solamente toca un puntito en el plano
que es el punto cuyas coordenadas son x
y z no te confundas entre puntos
vectores y planos y porque me voy a
tomar estos dos vectores porque yo
quiero construir un vector que esté
encima del plano fíjate bien qué pasa si
yo me tomo la diferencia de estos dos
vectores la diferencia del vector x
menos el vector x0 x menos el vector y 0
nos dibujaba este vector de aquí
recuerdas esto lo vimos en los primeros
vídeos acerca de vectores este vector
que estoy tomando aquí es el vector x
menos x 0 porque
que era que el vector tal que si
nosotros le sumamos x0 nos daba equis y
fíjate como si empezamos en x0 llegamos
después de x0 más x menos x0 al vector
equis y bueno ahora sí ya tengo un
vector sobre el plano este vector si
está sobre el plano dejame dibujar de
aquí este vector si existe en el plano y
como existe en el plano entonces el
vector x menos x0 va a cumplir que es
perpendicular al vector normal esto es
perpendicular al vector normal entonces
déjame escribirlo aquí como estos dos
existen en el plano entonces este vector
el x menos x0 es un vector perpendicular
al vector normal porque recuerda que
todo lo que estuviera en el plano era
perpendicular al vector normal por
construcción al vector n y bueno cómo se
vería el vector n así que déjame
escribirlo aquí si estos dos son
perpendiculares entonces van a cumplir
que en el que era el vector normal
déjenme ponerlo aquí este es el vector
cuyas entradas es el n1 n2 y
y bueno ya tengo x menos x 0 voy a
intentar llegar a esta ecuación con
estos dos datos que ya conozco
utilizando siente sencillamente el
producto punto y que además la
diferencia de estos dos vectores existe
en el plano voy a intentar llegar a la
ecuación cartesiana que nosotros tenemos
aquí a x más bella en macetas e igual a
0 entonces que sé que el vector n punto
producto punto por el vector x menos x 0
espero que todo vaya bien hasta aquí es
más déjame hacerlo de una manera más
visible déjame dibujar lo que arriba
este vector n es este vector que estoy
dibujando aquí es un vector que es
perpendicular al plano por lo tanto está
así este es mi vector en recuerdas
director normal entonces mi vector
normal es perpendicular al vector x
menos x0 porque el vector x menos x0 es
un vector que está sobre el plano
entonces
n punto el vector x menos x0 esto es
igual a 0 por definición de ángulo entre
dos vectores por la definición de
perpendicularidad así que bueno ya que
tenemos esto que es esto
tenemos aquí vamos a ir sustituyendo
esto me queda n1 n2 n3 punto x x 0 pero
x menos x 0 es el vector x quitarle el
vector x 0 y esto me va a quedar pues x
menos x 0 y después de menos de 0 en
segunda componente y por último me
quedaría zeta ceta 0 estoy restando
componente a componente con la
definición de diferencia y esto tiene
que ser igual a 0 porque son
perpendiculares y bueno si utilizamos la
definición de producto punto que me va a
quedar aquí pues me queda n 1 que va a
multiplicar a la primer componente de
este vector n 1 x x x 0 + n 2 que va a
multiplicar a la segunda componente es
decir n 2 x menos de 0 más n 3 que
multiplica la tercer componente es decir
n 3 que multiplica a z menos cero y esto
igual a cero y aunque no aparezca esta
es la ecuación de un plano esto que
tenemos aquí es exactamente igual a
tener a x más bella 60 igual a de o
perdón perdón desigualdad de no sé
porque puse 0 perdón aquí es d
aquí es a x más bella más lenta se
iguala de puede ser cualquier número
real no forzosamente tiene que ser un
plano que corte en el origen bueno ya
que tenemos esto créanme esto es lo
mismo que esta forma que tenemos aquí y
además vamos a verlo con un ejemplo para
que quede mucho más claro no voy a tomar
a un vector que va a ser perpendicular a
este plano al plano al que yo quiero
encontrar en su ocasión y este vector
perpendicular es el 13 menos 2 y a
continuación también me voy a tomar un
punto con un punto del plano ya la hice
y el punto del plano que me van a dar va
a ser el punto vamos a tomarnos uno
sencillo va a ser el punto 1 2 3 y por
lo tanto me voy a tomar como el vector
x0 el vector 123 recuerda que era que el
vector cuyas componentes eran cada una
de las coordenadas de este punto que me
daban y bueno ahora me voy a tomar otro
punto en este plano él va a ser el punto
x dz y con esto voy a construir un
vector cuyo punto inicial sea el origen
y cuyo punto final sea este punto
cualquiera en el plano y bueno a
continuación cómo construir la ecuación
de mi plano pues voy a utilizar lo mismo
que ya vimos
a tomar la diferencia de x men x 0 quien
es x - x 0 bueno déjenme escribirlo aquí
x menos x 0 va a ser aquí el vector rojo
es un vector tal que a cada componente
de x le voy a quitar cada componente del
vector x0 y me va a quedar x menos 1 en
la primer componente y menos dos en la
segunda componente y z menos 3 en la
tercer componente y recuerda que este
vector existe en el plano por lo que
acabamos de ver este vector si está en
nuestro plano por lo tanto si yo me tomo
el vector normal punto el vector x - x 0
entonces me va a definir una ecuación y
además va a cumplir que esto tiene que
ser igual a 0 es decir el vector 13
menos 2 que es mi vector normal punto el
vector x menos x0 que es el vector x -1
y -2 7 menos 3 tiene que ser igual a 0
porque son perpendiculares y entonces me
va a quedar la suma de la multiplicación
de componente a componente 1 por x menos
1 es x menos 13 porque menos 2 - 2 que
multiplica a z menos 3 y esto es igual a
0 y de aquí pues vamos a ver que podemos
reducir
déjame cambiar de color a un color un
poco más feliz porque estamos felices de
que ya va a acabar el vídeo me va a
quedar x menos 1 aquí lo voy a poner x 1
+ 3 - 6 lo único que hice fue
multiplicar por 3 y después menos 12
está más 6 y esto es igual a 0 y si te
das cuenta que ya podemos reducir un
poco menos 6 + 6 se van y este menos 1
que tengo aquí lo voy a pasar del otro
lado entonces al final me va a quedar x
+ 3 y menos 12 está igual a 1 y qué
creés esta ecuación de un plano las
ecuaciones que habíamos visto de forma
cartesiana esto está muy sencillo porque
ya encontramos la ecuación de un plano
con solamente un vector perpendicular y
un punto en el plano y bueno realmente
no teníamos que hacer todo esto que
hicimos aquí pudimos también utilizar
toda esta fórmula que habíamos
construido aquí arriba que era ya el
producto punto del vector normal por
nuestro vector que estaba en el plano
esto de aquí sería uno que multiplica a
x menos x 0 pero x0 valía 1 recuerda que
es la primera componente que teníamos en
nuestro
x 0 + n 2 que es 3 que multiplica al
menos 2 que la segunda componente de
nuestro vector x 0 - 2 que multiplica z
menos 3 y esto tiene que ser igual a 0 y
al final estamos llegando justo a lo
mismo esto es lo mismo que teníamos aquí
abajo y por lo tanto vamos a llegar a x
+ 3g menos 12 está igual a 1 que por
cierto recuerda que es la forma
cartesiana de ver a un plano hemos
llegado a lo mismo y bueno esta
información que vamos a construir es
bastante útil cuando hablamos de tres
dimensiones y de cosas de programación y
también de las matemáticas que estamos
viendo